can a brief comment for Sky News on the
doping Revelations I've just heard about
it now as well so I've got no comment at
the moment but I'll be in touch I'll
give you my verdict
does it does it mean that is it
essentially recognition that you cheated
in the fight never I've never cheated
I'm a retired fighter and at the same
time
um
you can see by my performance
my performance against Kell Brook wasn't
the best performance art so he sense
that you lost the fight I lost the fight
and obviously if I if I went in there
and not kill Boca is different I've
never cheated in my life I'm the one who
wanted the testing on on the fight and
also
um
the amount look the amount that it was I
mean that was in my system could have
been by shaking people's hands and it
was I did it was a bodybuilding drug get
into your system that is the question
isn't it I don't know what I don't know
what what drug was in my system ostering
Austrian so and at the same time a
license for human consumption guys I'm
really sorry we need to prepare a
statement yeah I'll I'll be in touch I'm
gonna give my My Views anyway but like I
said I've never cheated in my life I
will never cheat I like I am a retired
fighter so I've got a two-year by now
which is quite strange and funny that
they run me I'm already so tired anyway
so no comeback plans then clearly combat
plans at all but like I said I've never
cheated and I never will and that's just
not something I would do